- What is yoga?
Oh...
(sitar music)
- Obviously everyone knows
yoga comes from India, duh.
- For me, yoga is as appealing
as watching paint dry.
- Yeah, I can name a few yoga positions.
There's like, the downward dog.
- I know a bit about yoga,
I'm just a lazy sack of
shit so I don't do it.
(sitar and drum music)
- [Instructor] There are so many different
definitions of what yoga is.
Traditionally speaking,
yoga is sanskrit for "yoke,"
which is also translated to "union."
Inhale, exhale.
And that's what it's gonna look like
when you traditionally understand what the
sun salutation is.
Inhale, hands up to the sky,
and exhale, and we are
going to bend at our waist.
(sitar music)
- Like I feel like the
first step into an exorcism.
- Am I gonna be in pain tomorrow?
I feel like I'm gonna be in pain.
I feel like I'm just
gonna be in constant pain
for the next two months.
My back hurts, so much.
Like so much.
(sitar music)
- How long have we been doing this?
Two weeks?
Feels like forever.
- Yoga's actually kind of fun.
And I think that's partly
because we're in these classes
with a bunch of our colleagues
that we know and like.
- The thing that caught me
off-guard the most about yoga
was the rage I was
experiencing the first week.
And my body's total
rejection of the practice.
So I was doing a good
job not feeling that rage
that I was feeling a lot in the beginning,
but now today it came back in full force,
and I was swearing.
- The most challenging pose is anything
where I have to go across my body.
Cause, to be honest,
yoga with big boobs is a
little more challenging.
- I think I feel better so far.
Like, my body isn't totally
rebelling against me
at all hours of the
day, which is a change.
- Two weeks in and I
don't think there's been
that much of a change in my body.
- [Instructor] I think
people get discouraged really
easily when they begin.
You have to want to do
it, you have to really
want to learn, you have to
really have an open mind.
And if you've never done
yoga, you don't really have
that opened mind yet.
So you need to begin to develop it.
- I feel alright.
- Yoga's fine.
- Yoga feels like a drag before it starts,
and then after it's done I'm like
"oh, that was pretty good."
- We're half way through, I feel great.
I've only been doing this for a month
and I can already see the changes.
I'm getting better, I'm
getting more flexible,
I'm getting stronger, I can see it.
The results are real.
- [Instructor] Down,
inhale, upward facing dog.
Exhale, downward facing dog.
- Henry hates the chanting,
but I really like the chanting in yoga.
- Chanting is uh, it's something we do.
- I am not connected with the chanting.
I'm not connecting to
the spirituality of it
in a lot of ways.
- I can't help but have a
really stupid grin on my face.
You close your eyes but
I'm smiling the whole time.
We go "om..." I don't know the words.
- It's just not really my thing.
I like that I'm doing this.
- [Instructor] T Lo, bring your arms
a little closer together.
- If I were to go somewhere by myself,
I don't think I would feel
comfortable doing that.
- Oh my favorite posture, um...
(sitar music)
- Can I just lay down on my back?
(laughs)
- Now when we started
this, I was like here.
And like I was burning, now...
- I don't know, it just
feels like a good stretch.
I'm not gonna answer questions
while I do it though.
(laughs) It's bullshit.
- So I decided it was time to go
to the chiropractor.
We took an x-ray, turns out,
I have fucking scoliosis.
Look at this, that's my spine.
Right there, that's like,
where all my pain is.
In a weird way I'm like
really relieved to know
that I'm not crazy, and
like I actually have a thing
that we now know and I can fix.
And like I asked him, "what should I do?"
he said "yoga."
- [T Lo] I'm glad I'm doing these classes,
because I would have
never taken it upon myself
to go to yoga classes.
Starting out in this
environment with my coworkers
is probably the best way to go,
because we're all just having fun
and joking with each other.
- I didn't know we were doing that.
- Uh, God.
- That terrifies me.
- I'm walking down to
my first non-Buzzfeed
yoga class in my life.
- I'm about to take a class on my own.
- That's the sweatiest I've been in years.
- We did shit I've never done before.
- I was probably not
the worst person there,
but I was definitely bottom five.
- There's no way I
would ever pay for yoga.
- There's definitely no
laughing, it's not a fun class.
- There was this guy with
a man bun next to me,
he seemed to know
exactly what he was doing
I did not like being next to him at all.
- It's like a reminder that, oh yeah,
just doing two months of yoga is like,
a drop in a bucket of
what it takes to actually
be good at yoga.
- I'm ready to keep doing this,
and be come a full-blown yogi.
I don't like saying that, it sounds gross.
- [Instructor] That's a
really relative question.
Like I still don't feel
lie I have a fully grounded
yoga practice, and I've
been 10 years plus in.
Now for other people it could take months.
(cheering)
- I already kind of miss doing yoga.
I don't know how much
you captured on film,
but it was such a fun atmosphere
for any kind of work out class.
There was lots of laughing, lots of jokes,
lots of give and take.
- Here's the thing,
I thought yoga was
something a little different
than yoga turns out to be.
- I think the biggest
misconception of yoga
is that it's easy.
- I think yoga's helped
me address the things
I'm unhappy about.
- I don't do physical activity
unless I have to do it.
Yoga is definitely a physical activity.
- I've been in pain and I was like
"Ah, I'm just out of shape, ha."
But no, I have a fucking curve in my back.
Look at that, I'm pointing to the graphic
I assume you're gonna put in.
(clap)
- Fucking earned this shavasana.
- Oh God.
Best pose.
(chanting)
- As soon as it gets easy,
you have to push yourself
to make it hard again.
And that's um..
I don't know, kind of dumb.